psychologists are telling us that one of
the reasons
why transsexuality is up and this is
non-muslim so from a psychology
perspective
is because of the breakdown in the
family structure child looking at his
mother
taking the father's role in the father
taking the mother's rule and so on now
having said that how should a man act
right if you got a flex you're not a man
if you got a flex that you're you're a
man you're not a man
being a man is
[Music]
first and foremost the prophet salallahu
he said that
basically when a group of companies came
to him and asked you know we're dealing
with these horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the prophet he said
that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith good news
in the prosthetist he said it's a sign
of high iman and think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
assalamu
we're live so another day
another day another dua all right
another day another dua but in today's
video
we're going to be asking the sheikh a
whole bunch of questions
i'll let someone else take over
bro you got the wrong one bro that's the
next episode
all right so you guys can ask me
questions well what kind of back and
forth on this side
i mean um first thing it's always a
pleasure being on with you guys man you
guys are always the fun guys man
so inshallah this will be a fun uh
session and
people enjoy it and uh we always try to
encourage everybody
like subscribe share help the brothers
out mashallah they're doing good work
um so let me just begin with this so
i i get a lot of comments uh why do you
dress this way why don't you wear this
why don't you wear that right not only
pay attention to people because they can
say whatever they want
as a muslim we have some boundaries in
sharia which you can
cannot wear right as a woman she has her
own auras
hijab and all that men have their own
aura on their own hijab and all of that
and it is like not imitating kuffar and
all this kind of stuff that that
obviously we have to live by
after that any uh there are things that
are muslim
that would prefer like the rasool allah
that time
was like a though like the longer upper
garment alhamdulillah
it's something nice imagine it's
authentic and so on
uh rasulallah tied the imam on the head
of the
as if
narration and he tied it without uh
if he tied it without a tail in the back
right without a loose end
rasulallah he untied it and re-tied it
with the loose end
and he told him this is better this is
clear this is the way you should wear it
so those things
are more about being prefer
right for example the
people that wear the turban without the
tail like we see in
egypt and some of the sufia and some of
the turkish and others
rasulallah disapproved of that right so
as if the iem has
in that this is the way of the kuffar
so you shouldn't wear it that way right
some of the tab your own said
shaytan this is like the way of shaytaan
and if somebody wears it today nobody
says anything because nobody has
knowledge to know
where the boundaries are you get one
group of people that tell you you gotta
wear sunnah clothing
what's sunnah clothing you don't really
think the whole concept of sunnah
is about clothing right right
and then they're like they're lost right
and they'll be waiting like an indian
or pakistani or afghani dress and they
think this is sunnah coding
and no that's not a concept right
rasulallah
that was the clothing of the people at
the time but
there are some aspects for example he
forbid isabel hanging the pope
down even though that was common at the
time so now as a muslim we should have
our pants
as a man above the ankles perfectly
makes sense
good right but past that there's going
to be clothing that represents you as a
muslim right somebody sees you walking
down the street
and they see that you're muslim and that
might be good for dawa at certain times
you're going like when i go to the park
people are always like wear jeans
i don't want to wear jeans i'm not going
to wear it because you tell me to wear
it right
but i wear a sob or the shadow arcanes
or all these kinds of things so that
when i'm walking
many people may come up to me or ask me
hey why are you dressed like that or hey
i like that dress or whatever
and it opens up a bob of dawah
alhamdulillah excellent right
but at the same time it doesn't mean
that i have to dress down right
i can dress in any way that is within
the boundary
like i'm at work right now i have a work
shirt on it was a hot day
i have my hat on representing my city uh
and there's nothing wrong with that
right like this is the problem right
people have made
cultural practices into the religion or
they're trying to act as if uh
there is no dress code in islam when
really the best way is to look at the
what allah has ordained what the prophet
islam has ordained
and then keep yourself within those
bounds you know so
you know and this is something that i
think is very important why people
need to seek some people come up with
really strange opinions nowadays
like i heard somebody talk the other day
about niqab and they were like nepal's
not a part of islam
what where did you get that from whether
you take it to be muslim
that's a different masala but from ebony
onwards i mean you got sahabah and you
got tabion and others that have
discussed the masala and discussed it
so for you to come with something with
that left field just means you're
ignorant
like don't speak go learn something
right so you know that's why
i thought today i'm going to put my hat
on
my shoulder
um you hear you hear a lot of people
saying things like you know you can't do
thicker
unless you use it and um this that the
other
and and subhanallah it is a very
ignorant way of thinking and something
that
um i learned in my classes um
and well the people try and do this
really really like
false and a logical deduction and
it's like they're going to the last step
like yeah they go to the last step
and they they forget um the quran they
forget
they forget the sahaba and all of that
let me explain something about piastro
people don't know what they ask means
90 of the people i speak to think means
that a scholar deduces something that is
not what prayas means that is
right so how does the shariah work
and this is very important for everybody
so we have the quran the kalam allah
the words of allah nazar it has been
revealed
it was not it was not created excellent
right this is a first
place we get our rulings then allah in
the quran
orders us to follow the prophet
salallahu tells the prophet to explain
the rulings to us guilt tells us about
the hikmah that was revealed and so on
so you get the second which is
the sunnah which is the recording of the
sunnahs called hadi
right it's not like hadith and sunnah
are two different things like this is
again
sunnah according to this allah of the
hadith there's anything
well how will you me and and and him
today know what rasool did are we
seeing him did we have any kind of
camcorders or cell phones no
that knowledge of the sunnah is recorded
in hadith literature that's what a
hadith is right
in terminology right so these two and
when it's authentic
we check it unlike the other religions
that don't even have any system of
checking anything
we check the narrations to make sure
they're authentic when you have an
authentic narration then khalas you have
now the second source of the sharia
third you have idjima
the earlier of islam when they come to a
consensus
like not just like hanafi's and sheikh
hayes when the scholars come together
the prophet
told us that my ummah will not come
together on
misguidance right so we know that that
becomes
a proof for us the fourth is us yes how
does chaos work
does not work on things that
were there in the time of salaam and we
have evidences for right
so if somebody says fajr is somebody who
goes hmm in our time
i think we should make three this is my
chaos
you don't know what chaos means is a
system
right for example rami if i asked you
today
is met halal is what how wrong
crystal meth is it no it's not
man you guys don't know what method is
you guys live in that clean life
where's that crackhead if that crystal
method is uh
they'll be right
so when you said meth is not halal
i can tell you find me an ayah that says
not
well there's no eye in the quran right
that is math that mentions meth
tell me a hadith that says heroin show
me a hadith
that says heroin is haram well obviously
it's not going to come right so
here we have this very practical thing
called
they ask what does it do it it brings
the assad the the original ruling
for example rasool allah said every
intestine is a hammer
it is as alcohol and every hammer is
haram
so everything that intoxicates will come
under the ruling of hammer
from the hadith so what we do we look at
that
and we do we extend that ruling out to a
new situation because that's how
practical the sharia is
right that's how beautiful islam is it
is
applicable at all times in all places so
now we use
on alcohol we take that meth
heroin whatever else you want to fill in
the blank that that that
intoxicates your mind would be haram
based on that chaos that's what
means right um i'll give you another
example just you know
this was a very easy one so it's gonna
be a little bit harder right
can you make salah while you're on a
plane
right meaning you're you're you're
traveling you're in the air
can you make salah now all of us would
probably be like yeah you could i mean
if you can stand and depending on
knuckle you could be sitting in but
but you could right and then somebody
could ask you where's your talib
we will say well rasul he meets
right so now he's traveling he's moving
and he made salah
now for the farah he stood that's a
different issue about standing and
sitting
but he did make salah on a
transportational any means right
so we say we say you couldn't make salon
a plane
now when we go to the moon and which
makes along the moon well i think there
is some shuuk that have written books on
salah on
in space we're using tayas that's how
practical the shariah is but prayas is
not somebody just sitting there
coming up with ruling like somebody
somebody comes out like a totally
off the wall ruling against the quran
and sunnah then you're like where'd you
get that from
there like you can tell that they don't
know what means
yeah yeah and it's really important i'm
glad you made that distinction
i want to ask about something you
mentioned um at the beginning when
you're talking about the
the order of uh the sources so you
mentioned obviously quran first
then sunnah sahabah sayings of the
companions and all of that
um and then chaos and everything um some
madahid
do have it in that order specifically
some of that like imam shafi rahim allah
um they put the quran in the
hadith the authentic hadith on the same
level when it comes to
legislative um um like rulings basically
so so i mean
yes and no meaning that in reality all
madahib
and i've studied uh
kind of agree on this the the
distinction is more
in semantics meaning do we say
that the hadith is any less of a source
in sharia no
it is also part of white do we say there
is a difference of course
there are no dif ayat there are hadith
there are no
any ayats that we say there is a club in
them because we know the
the the the order of the quran was
preserved
and so on so for example
he also discusses that the first places
that we get the ruling from is the quran
for example allah says
and that order is in the quran right our
base there is the quran
now we will say well how would you
establish salah
as somebody who rejects hadith will then
tell you well
you just pray the way the people pray
like
okay where did you get that from where
in the quran does allah you do what the
peoples do right
right and that's why the hadith
rejecters are really for unrejecters
right
uh somebody else who rejects hadith may
come back and say well you just pray any
way you want you just go to the beach
and look at the sun
like well where did you get that method
from should we follow the rasool
salaam the one that was revealed on or
should we just follow some dude
in buffalo new york at the beach or
whatever
oh right so so then you get these these
kind of people that don't know what
they're talking about and then somebody
will say fajr is one rakah somebody will
say
somebody they just make up their own
religion and their how are their desires
become
but allah told us to obey the prophet
so here now we have the hukam in the
quran
how to fulfill that the details of fajr
being rakatane and bohar being four and
other being four
mother being three and aisha being four
and the taslim
and how many roku and how many should
all of that comes
so this is there no doubt when you have
something in the quran or sahih hadith
no madhhab can take ijma against
they go to surah because it's
true right when there is no doubt it
will be in line with the misuse
right but it may clarify something
that yani may not be
evident in the quran of hadith but the
islam based on those that came to a
contest i'll give you an example
if you have water uh
that is more than
i'm not going to go too deep into the
massage here but it's a large amount of
water
and some najasa falls in it and it
so much filth falls in it that it
changes
its color taste or smell there are
hadith on them but
they're about this but they're weak but
for example he documented the consensus
of the muslim ummah
that if so much nadasa falls in it that
it changes these qualities
then yani it will become najis
right so now this
ma becomes a dali for us right so so
this is
kind of how it actually works in this
but in pretty much any agreement the the
differences in in
in issues get to be for example should
you use a mursal hadith
hadith what the sahabi is missing is
there a jar not a ja
what if you have a saying of a sahabi
and then you have hadith
which one do you give precedence to
which sahabis sayings do you give
present to in which aspect like
in these things then you get some of
madagasu
of obedience to the quran the sunnah the
izma and
being a general method and the baharia
have any
other mother that you know they had some
issues with us but even then they had
their own usual for using it
so on but the main point here really is
look
seek knowledge i mean learn
you know this this is an obligation on
you you know
and if you don't know don't talk people
that talk about niqab not being a part
of islam like like have you ever opened
a book
open up surat uh and azab look at that
look at that look at that
look at the works of albany
open those books up read and then speak
what i don't understand is why don't
people like to speak without knowing
like if you don't know who told you to
speak stay quiet like look if you guys
ask me
um what is the
square root of 20 million 30 whatever i
don't know like i would like
i don't know man i mean go ask rami or
something
somebody who may know better than me
right
even in debates you know in this recent
debate when
i was asked a question about which ayat
came from i don't know let me go look it
up
right but when you talk at the mouth
without knowing then you come out like
hammer time
saying stuff that just you know gets
proven in front of your face
and you make a fool out of yourself
right yeah so this is a
nasiha to a lot of the
the a lot of the students and then a lot
of the
regular muslims especially those on
youtube and facebook and twitter
look seek knowledge you know go go look
we have we have
it's not like you have to leave and go
to another country or something
subhanallah
you could be like you know in scotland
and allah would make a way for you you
could be in
china you could be in japan if nothing
else
honey you could you could go to the
videos we like our channel
that has all the doors free you don't
have to sign up no not to give your
email address or anything
we have phil we have hadith we have the
science of judging hadith we have a
seerah nabuia
go watch them if you don't want to watch
ours no problem alhamdulillah
find a good scholar student of knowledge
somebody you can rely on who's upon the
evidence is
watch it learn ask questions i mean
it's so simple but look at us nowadays
man this is a weird situation where
yes may allah protect us from that and
i'm so glad you brought that up because
i found it to myself because my first
i'd say
three years two three years of
practicing islam alhamdulillah
i was on that solo journey that solo
mission listening to different people
online
and some of what i heard was completely
wrong which is honestly it's scary it's
a problem and we'll talk about that
inshaallah but
i realized once i i you know joined a
proper like islamic institution and
actually i started learning under a
teacher
uh under a scholar and all of that allah
i realized that
um in my personal humble opinion as a
student
to me it seems like you need both your
independent
research and your own journey seeking
knowledge reading the books of the the
classical scholars reading the quran
reading
from credible you know scholars and
doing that
on your own but also it's people under
estimate how important it is to have
someone you can turn to someone
knowledgeable to actually ask them
specific things
because a lot of the time we read
something and we completely
misunderstand it
so many times i've heard quotes from
imam shapiro
and and other scholars that say
something like um allah you know
allah exists without a place and then
this entire
ashrae movement is backed up saying you
know um
doesn't mean what you think it means and
you may be a catherine bro i have people
who didn't return
because of that man
and that's very important because when
you look at a qualifying mind
first and foremost you look at the
authenticity of them secondly look at
the context of them and so on
and when you have i mean like like the
whole ashari mataroodi the thing right
let's just let's just take it very
simple right and i'd like to like to be
clear right
look allah review the quran
he didn't teach us he didn't teach us he
didn't teach us
he taught us the quran and whatever
needed to be explained from it he
explained it
and he told us we are leaving you with
the deen that the day is like the night
meaning then and the night is like the
day that
clear i'm not there's nothing good
except that i told you about it
there's nothing that except that i
warned you about it
like you know it actually goes back to a
dilla right
and then you have that first beautiful
generation of sahab
wonderful didn't have to go study greek
philosophy they didn't have to study
kalam they didn't have to get into
mantra they didn't do any of that like
they would the ayah was there they
believed in it you know when
imam malik and i'm saying the next
generation right imam malik and he was
asked about
he said there was no like we see in the
quran
and the kefir the how is unknown
we don't ask like what does like how you
know like this this no it really means
this and it doesn't mean that and
you know no we don't ask this question
this this question is a bit i like to
get into this
philosophical debate it's a vida it's in
the quran we believe in it how do we
believe in it the way that allah reveals
it
simple the sahaba we're good with this
if you look at imam sheikh and then
actually that was talked about
right or imam ali read that one of imam
read the qual of imam or the salaf of
this ummah
the great imma they would say
it will say not knowing this is
knowledge
and having knowledge of that's ignorance
them with their references and all of
that right so how simple is islam
look allah said it we believe it
rasulallah said it authentically we
believe it
how does jannah have so much faith
well bro when you get there insha allah
you can find out
allah or when um when professor krauss
asks hamza zoro says what is the soul
and he's like when you die you'll find
out
beautiful
yeah and i i like that because a lot of
people can y'all hear me good
yeah i gotta get closer we can hear oh
yeah
um but a lot of people i would almost
say that's like a disease of the mind
because you know before i came to islam
um anytime i would uh
learn something i would always ask why
and i would try to go deeper and deeper
and deeper and it's like brother it's a
never ending
like even when you find the answer your
mind is giving up for the next thing the
next thing the next thing
and um yeah so it makes sense
i mean there are some things you should
question and we're not against questions
but some things
you will not be able to fully grasp with
the human mind that's just a fact
for example if somebody says hey this is
the quran feel free to be like hey where
is that in the quran which ayah
sure no problem said this hey
where is the hadith is it authentic ask
the question no problem
how do we know it's authentic no problem
ask this question right
but if somebody asks what's the last
number
it doesn't matter there is no last
number right any number you give me i'll
add a one to it right
and if you sit there and just
contemplate on that you just give
yourself a headache
right you'll your brain will will not be
able to
do anything except to sleep except just
to accept it
right and that's what islam is right we
submit ourselves to allah if allah said
it it is
right so when you look at things like
where's the end of the universe
and when i was a little kid and as a
foolish kid i would look up at the sky
sometimes and i just wonder like
where's the end right and i'll just
contemplate like think about it
like it just goes and goes and goes and
goes there must be like a
n like in your mind because you're human
and the human state of mind
is filled with restrictions right
everything is got a beginning and end
right
like your house is a beginning and end
even if you live in a baller pad like
angel but uh right your your car has a
beginning and end
even if it's like any stretched out limo
right but it still has a beginning and
end now
when you look at the sky you can't see
anything right so your mind your mind
puts a false end like there must be a
place
under the sky okay what's after that
nothing
what's nothing right if you go through
this you just give yourself a headache
right because these things are not meant
for our
human comprehension these are things
where allah has shown a certain thing to
be like look
there are certain things you need to
know allah is one this is the quran
this is the prophet ask your questions
you need to know
will know under need to understand can
understand certain things you have to
leave to allah
all right now even seeing allah is not
possible in dunu
if you look at the discussion the quran
and the seeing of allah
in dunya you can't see allah and these
are ayat and quran that establishes and
so on as well
but in you will right and that's a very
interesting point because
in dunya we're limited everything around
us is limited
everything has a beginning we were born
we'll die it was the time then this
office wasn't here the time
is going to be gone so on and so on
right so
everything has that limit so when we're
in this limited state we cannot see a
lot
we cannot handle it but after
death we will transition out of this
temporary life
into an everlasting life and in that
everlasting life you will be able to
comprehend the vastness of jannah and
you will be able to understand
that the never-ending and you will be
able to comprehend uh
the the greatness of the the bounties
that allah has given upon us in reality
and so on
and at that time you can then see allah
and that's the greatest pleasure in
jannah is to see allah
how beautiful is that right when did you
think about
any all these years of making sujud and
making this
praying to allah and then you actually
get to hear allah you actually get to
see allah where you actually get to
uh yeah has a short poem and it's so
beautiful about you know i mean
uh i don't want to get too deep into
this but it's such a
a thing that may allah grant us all the
sight of allah
it's like you know how you know how we
we want to see things in in this dunya
in this life like
you might want to travel you might want
to see the uh the philippines
you might want to see the mao dives you
might want to go to thailand you might
want to go to russia you might want to
go
to the netherlands wherever it is is san
diego
yeah oh okay all right go ahead rip it
rip it hard boy but um we want to see
these things because to us it's like oh
it's beautiful
that's the creation of allah but it's
like
allah is going to be beyond
anything that's been created so i i
think
i think you're right man i think you're
right and i also think
that um we shouldn't understand
everything 100
because if we did then this wouldn't be
a test
right yeah yeah we get this all the time
people are like you know atheists will
come up to
both and and and and you know like
we don't get a lot of views on the
atheist videos but i think those are the
funniest
because the atheists they just got
nothing
they'll be like why doesn't god just put
a big sign in the sky that's his god
right like imagine that right like
imagine you walk into an
examination hall you go you go take your
whatever sats or you know you're taking
a test
and you know the teacher's like hey
here's the test here's your plan here's
your time limit go go at it you're like
why don't you just put the answers
like oh okay there's a test for you yeah
all the answers are right
already written in great job right
subhanallah you know and the amazing
thing is
if there was a sign in the sign in the
sky they just said allah
like a big huge sky all all the time
some atheists will come over the reason
why it's there
you know you know what it is it's really
the winds that
hit the particles like
i mean think about this right i have a
video on the
splitting of the moon if you haven't
seen it you've got to watch it insha
allah right
we talk about the evidences from the
quran and also from the authentic
narration but also
from many of the enemies of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi sallam
who were who were adversaries they were
they were there were enemies
and they saw this and they documented it
and they talked about it and and
and some of them later became muslim and
some of them never became muslim and we
talk all the evidences and books and
references are in the video right
those people saw the splitting of the
moon
like rasul what do you want we want a
miracle yeah what do you want
split the moon okay
clearer than that and there are those
that did become muslim but there are
those that still didn't become muslims
they saw the moon split
right they asked the other arab
travelers the tribes that were out
in trade groups when they came back
right when those travelers came back
they asked them hey we saw this did you
see it as well because
maybe did some magic on us but he
couldn't have done it
on you right and they were like yeah we
saw it
i mean these are people that were
outside of makkah and they said malik
reported this he was in medina at the
time
right then you have and again i mean i
give all the references in the video but
you have documentation from india
now as a disclaimer those
documents do not match our level of
checking in hadoop right because our
level of checking is way deep right
who heard it who was the first person to
report does it conflict and all this
and if we go nobody goes deep like we do
in hadith no historian
nobody right one of the brothers
masha'allah he has an idea we'll see if
we do one of these days uh on his show
we're gonna do like a
a hadith style checking of the bible you
know
and see how it comes out but it'll be
fun uh
but anyway but in hadith we go really
deep those oral traditions
some written some later and things will
not match our
detail analysis but that is accepted
history there there are monuments made
to it even
enemies of islam for example any uh
people that are
you know the modi or whatever his name
is even he
you know makes little gold replicas and
sends it to saudi kings and stuff
that's how well accepted is about the
mosque of the one who saw this and
became muslim and built it and so on
i mean in their textbooks in their into
multiple sources
hindus will say this is accepted history
that people in india
saw the splitting of the moon right so i
imagine that
like such a miracle in front of the
people
and there's still people that didn't
become muslim so hidayah is from allah
allah has given us so many signs look at
in everyday life how many sciences allah
give us
right every breath you say think about
this like i talked to an atheist i told
him
look at how complex the human body is
right look at the
eye look at the the brain the lungs the
kidneys
everything has a function everything has
such perfection right
even your eyebrows you know you you
never think what are eyebrows for right
like they're just kind of there but
i had a friend who was barbecuing you
burnt off his eyebrows right
and he couldn't walk in the sun like he
couldn't walk his eyes couldn't take it
and then you realize these eyebrows
actually block sun rays
i mean everything has a purpose so ask
them how did that get to be
right how did you know nose hairs we're
all
busy trimming nose hairs you know nose
here stop bacteria from going up into
your body
it's a very essential thing when you
make wudo when you put that water on the
nose and flush it out
it takes all those germs and bacterias
out before it gets in
i mean like look at that they're gonna
say natural selection
excellent so let's go to natural
selection what does it mean natural
selection
meaning something had to be there to be
selected
right natural selection trust me i
i have a master's in hadith but i also
have executive mba we're going to go
here right this is a
medical device company that i'm sitting
at right now
if you need a longer neck
to reach certain foods and you have it
and the other animals don't
you will survive this is natural
selection simple example
great but that means you had to have a
longer neck to begin with
it has to be selected right
teeth how did you naturally select teeth
if the first organism didn't have them
right
eyeballs eyeballs can't function
without all of the the details and and
analysis that they have
if the eyeballs weren't able to see and
have the function of sight
there would be no benefit to just two
little soft balls on your head
right so natural selection does not
answer the question
of origin right so
what about if they say random genetic
mutation thank you
i was hoping you'd bring that up because
i was going to bring it up but i'm glad
you did
excellent random genetic mutation that
means
me you and angel and rami should all be
having
random mutations right
that means you should see somebody
walking around and not just one person
because
random mutation of a species right
if one person has something that can't
bring it to the whole species so that
means there should be people walking
around with horns
there should be people walking around
with feathers there should be people
walking around that
randomly got wings and and those wings
shouldn't be flexible and all that they
should be random
right that makes no sense
think it through yeah so let's say
yeah so what if they say natural
selection
through a random mutation so so then
again
you had to have had it in that
let's use the ix example right how do
you
randomly mutate to have a functioning
eye
you cannot it's not just it was just a
soft piece of flesh with no purpose to
it
and then one lens came to you see what
i'm saying
the eye has to have sight for it to be
of
value for natural selection and for it
to have sight
it had to be in functioning order it
cannot be random
yeah yeah yeah i'll give you an example
uh has a mic
in front of me right now
what if i told you nobody made that mic
he didn't go to some expensive store and
pay a lot of money to buy that store he
didn't order it online
sony or samsung or whatever rodeo road
whatever that is companies that make
mics
didn't make it over billions of years
randomly
a piece of dirt
mutated to develop a mic
right come on why not why not
billions of years that dirt
turned into a rock into a clump of sand
into metal somehow and and developed the
ability to pick up sound
and grew a usb or a
coaxial chord out of it randomly nobody
knows you're going against the law of
entropy
you're going from disorder to order
which shouldn't be wrong right
okay what about the human are you more
complicated or that might
or a lot more complicated you gave you
you gave the same
analogy you know i think you were yeah
it was a video of yours you were in a
lecture hall talking about hijab and all
that right
yeah i think you were talking about a
computer and stuff like that
yeah i remember that i give you things
all the time yeah but but the point here
is
atheists have to answer they just they
have no answer
they're just there to like talk but if
you ask them they have no answer
where'd we come from no answer what's
the purpose of life no answer what's
right and wrong
if somebody's atheist tell me what's
right from wrong
right why is it that it's wrong to kill
somebody
because you feel it's wrong well some
some dude somewhere is like hey
i think it's i mean i had friends
growing up that had fun there was
nothing wrong with killing somebody else
he got away with it right
so right so i mean why is it wrong to
kill somebody
well as a muslim i would tell you
because allah made haram in the quran
right
right i would tell you these evidences
right but as an atheist
is this your feeling so tomorrow if
society decides you know what slavery's
okay
we should enslave all chinese people
right
then i guess it is okay because if
society agrees on it
right there is no right and wrong in
atheists then there is no moral code
this is people's own opinions and and
you know
if you have four people you probably
have five opinions of what's right and
wrong so
so then you know society can't even
function like that right
this is the this is the things people
don't think about right bestiality you
know
whatever i mean i don't want to get you
know too explicit here
but all of that why is it wrong if
you're an atheist
we can tell you it's wrong because allah
made it our designer
our creator who knows best how we should
function told us this is how you should
and this is how you shouldn't
one last thing i want to touch on with
the eye oh the me let me touch on that
with what he said
i brought it it basically
it makes it objective right you know and
then
uh a lot of atheists will say oh well
there's there's no such thing as
objective
and i they but they don't they don't
even
believe in subjective or objective but
then when you ask them this question
they're like oh well
exactly like you said you know it's it's
something that we already have like the
ethics the moral companies like all
right but where's that comment but we
don't
we don't i mean think about it right i
mean as a society
the moral compass is very different in
different places
if you go to different countries some
some will consider capital punishment
immoral
some will not right some will consider
uh jails to be immoral if you i don't
know if you've ever seen a jail in
norway and all that and you know those
things look like vacation spots they got
xboxes and stuff right
when you show them uh a pin in the us
they're like that's torture that's
immoral right but in america we consider
texas they love to fry people they're
like that's death sentence away
right and many other states are like
that's immoral so who's going to decide
right even in society we haven't come to
a consensus and what's more on what's
not
what's what's i mean look at child labor
laws look at
you know i mean factory conditions in
china look at the massacre and
on genocide of the ubers our brothers
and sisters in china
the chinese government feels that that's
perfectly fine
biden said something about i don't know
about you know cultural whatever
but obviously yeah any human being would
be like nah that's not cool right
so so so this idea that humans have come
to like a consensus
on morality is this is a lie
i mean if you if you go to today
different cultures
even things like drinking alcohol and
things there's no consensus
i mean i got non-muslim co-workers that
don't drink alcohol because they feel
it's immoral
but i also have non-muslim co-workers
that
get drunk all the time right is it moral
or is it immoral
right as a muslim i'll tell you it's
haram why because my
it's not based on my deduction my
creator who knows better than me
right let me ask you a simple question
right let's say
you get the uh iphone 13
right and it's i mean i don't know what
it's going to be like right but let's
say it's like a crazy new design it's
like totally different right it's
nothing like which probably won't
because you know apple hasn't really
been
coming strong lately but right let's say
it is right
it's got this hologram that comes out
and all this crazy stuff you know like
whoa
this is cool right but the charging
system
water everything is different right
how would you know how to use it right
you're going to look for the user manual
like when you get it in the box you open
it a little user manual or you're going
to youtube a video of a trainer somebody
who knows it
maybe apple has instruction video they
have trainers that go out and show you
hey charge it like this not like this
don't put it in water
do it do this do that right the
manufacturer
knows how to use it if you on the other
hand rami decide you know what i'm going
to put in the microwave and see what
happens
well you might get a pretty good youtube
video but that cell phone is not going
to work
much longer right so so we
in experimentation don't know how to use
it we'll destroy it right
but the manufacturer that built it knows
how it should be used so
who made us allah we didn't make
ourselves
allah made us and that allah knows how
we should
best function so that allah then
sent a user manual with us right
everybody
had that guidance first and foremost in
your fitra
in yourself you know shirk is wrong when
you see somebody worshipping a
a rat you just look at them like
seriously bro
like right you know what's wrong
somebody steals they know what's wrong
they can justify in their mind all they
want but
you know and some societies like yeah
whatever it's capitalism big fish eat
little fish whatever right
but your fitra is there then allah sent
books
and he look at the mercy of allah he
didn't have to
right but allah sent the the the torah
the the the zaboor the injil
trainers so you've got like for us now
with the last revelation we have the
quran this is our user
it tells you your rights and wrongs and
the trainer sent
is the messenger sallallahu to show us
attractive that's why the
said is the walking quran to show us a
practical implementation
how to implement the quran right this is
the true guidance
otherwise people like you know what i
think we should eat by putting forks in
our eyes
go for it bro try it out let me know how
it goes
yeah they're backwards though in the
fact that if you ask them
about this they'll be like oh well no
there is such a thing as morals and
ethics i mean look a little
a little little kid a little kid he's
gonna think it's wrong to
kill someone like oh well okay that's
what fitra is
but then when you tell them to that when
you tell them that they're like oh no
no i don't believe in that i don't
believe but let's let's take a little
kid right
a kid's going to have no doubt to that
because allah right
but if you take the same little kid and
you and you raise him in the hood
and you raise him where he's got no
money and his parents are
not there mom's a crackhead dad's out
you know went to get milk never came
back kind of situation
right and then you take the same kid
genetically
same kid and you raise him in a really
pious household
parents and religious quran being read
salah being made
and then you ask both of them is drug
dealing
okay or not okay the one in the hood
that has to sell drugs to survive to
have money is going to be like bro
it's okay because i got to pay my bills
right and the one raised
even though in in the original fitnah
they both knew it but
the upbringing then sets up their morals
right the thing with atheists is then
they
have no more right if you look at i'll
give you
let's just take a contemporary example
right nowadays
you got this idea of trans transgender
right yeah
we're gonna go there let's get you guys
banned while we're on it
i mean not bad bro that's most of our
controversial viewed videos
i'm just messing with you guys right so
you got these dudes that's a fully
functioning it's not a unique it's not a
hemophilia diet it's not somebody with
any a sex gender
issues he's just a dude like fully
functioning man
and he decides i'm gonna wear a dress
and i'm a woman i'm gonna self-identify
as a woman today
all right so in islam that's haram
he forbids that dress up like woman and
so on and a woman
but an atheist would be like no you know
there's nothing wrong with it he
identifies
she identifies as a woman today all
right
now she wants to box as a woman
right now those same people
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh right well why
not
right let's let's imagine again in case
mike tyson watches this no offense
brother
but let's imagine if mike tyson decides
tomorrow you know what
i'm gonna self-identify as a woman right
and i'm gonna box the best woman boxer
that's out there
my tyson right you want to put him in a
ring with a woman i i'm a dude and i
don't want to be in the ring with mike
tyson right
and and imagine that right at that point
now you're like whoa whoa whoa whoa
hit the brakes like well why if you're
gonna take it that path then
go for it right let's say i want to
self-identify
as korean
okay yeah trans race is becoming a thing
right
i'm a monkey address me as a monkey
right
no you're offending me what the hell
right like
like you see it doesn't stop right
you know you had the you had the lg
stuff in the beginning then they
increased it with the t
and this and that and now there's a push
for pedophilia
you don't believe me google it right
well why i mean again if you're going to
have no moral
right and wrong then who said pedophilia
is wrong right
who said bestiality is wrong if you want
to go
and marry a chicken why not
right like islam alhamdulillah we have
the quran we have a hadith we have these
safety bearers of our creator telling
you this is not the way to go
right if you look at homosexuality
from a biological perspective from a not
not
even a religious perspective right a
species
needs more than two per
couple children to survive as a species
the core job of a species survival i
mean from a natural perspective right
so if everybody only had if every couple
only had two children we would be in
danger as a species
from our survival because some children
are going to die some are not going to
you know reproduce and so on be sterile
so your
your species starts to dwindle and if
you continue that you
you become the dodo bird right you're
finished right
now imagine if homosexuality becomes
prevalent
okay how many heterosexuals are you
going to have to have babies for you to
adopt
how many tests you babies are you going
to produce as a society
you start seeing that the natural
structure was not such
and that's why i'm not going to get into
detail but even that method
of relations is filled with pain and
rips and this and that because
it's not natural that's not the way it
was supposed to be
right and and and people realize and
then you know some you know i work with
a bunch of phd
atheists and stuff and they'll always be
like oh well that has
observed some homosexual behavior in
animals oh
there's also cannibalism in animals you
want to go down that mountain
no you don't so right right
and and and this this is something
amazing today
that when i was growing up and i'm not
that old
it was something very well understood
that this is something that is unnatural
but now it has become so strange that
you can't even talk about it
freedom of speech out the door you know
if you want to be like hey i don't think
my religion allows this
you know oh you know whatever bro do
what you got to do but
i want to speak the truth it's got to be
the way it is isn't there supposed to be
like this this new law that comes into
cali
that you must hire someone from the
spectrum in every business
whatever man california
you know whatever it is what it is man i
mean let them bring whatever is it and
people don't like our dua our imma that
are scared to talk about this don't
realize
that it's not going to be the end at
inclusion and not speaking about it
look at lutheran
right they put restrictions on him
saying you are
in you want to be clean you want to
leave this cleansing clean life
nope no gas no this no that they put
restrictions on him
right so if you don't stand up for
what's right
they're gonna come after you right i
mean it's not it's not just like
let it go right that's not the way it
works right
um when they saw them they didn't just
be like okay you be you
right look what happened and what's
interesting
in the quran the wife of luth is called
a cather
if you want to look at the example of
the catholic woman one of them is the
wife of luke
we don't know of her worshiping idols
but her kuffar was the acceptance and
support
of that which allah made today you got
imams and massages
but you know told us man there will
always be a group from my ummah on the
hub
and that's gonna be speaking the truth
and then and they will never be
overpowered
even if it's small you know
may allah make us from amongst them i
mean
look at our society and family structure
you know um i mean
in the 50s and 60s in america i'm just
talking about american society here i'm
not even like talking about
genderly and so on you had
a strong male role model
right um from a media perspective right
you had john wayne you had whatever you
know
all these guys that were these you know
fatherly figures
the you know whatever this is i don't
know that
i don't know the shows man i'm too young
for all that right but um
but you know you had these strong
figures
um and and you had
a society that promoted it right then
what happened
is in the next generation what did you
have you had al bundy
i don't know if you guys are old enough
to know how bundy married your children
is right
you had homer simpson right and then
past that you had
american dad or whatever i even watched
that stuff right that's that's past my
when i was like i'm done with tv style
time right
all of these figures became morons
the dad was an idiot like he didn't like
homer simpson was a [ __ ] marge was
always right homer didn't
everything he did was wrong he was just
this the his son didn't respect him his
daughter didn't respect you you see what
i'm saying
um al bundy from married with children
he was just you know
livestock he was horrible family didn't
respect him right
and you see this media attempt
to destroy the family structure
psychologists are telling us that one of
the reasons why
transsexuality is up and this is
non-muslim so from a psychology
perspective
is because of the breakdown in the
family structure child looking at his
mother
taking the father's role in the father
taking the mother's rule and so on
now having said that
how should a man act right if you got a
flex
you're not a man if you got a flex that
you're you're a man you're not a man
being a man is doing what allah has
ordained what the prophet absalom showed
us
this is manlihood right
subhanallah he was he was the best
example
right when it came time for salah he
went for salah he wasn't like
you know when it came time for jihad he
was there when it was time to leave the
community he was there
when it was time to make hijrah he made
the decision but when he came home he
washed dishes
he helped with the house i mean you know
washing this is an example but i mean
like
the things that as i said said that he
would be helping
with housley chores he would be sowing
his own shoes
right he didn't have to put up a fake
image
of an alpha he was an alpha right and
that's when you are a true
muslim living by the quran that
sets what you should be when you are
with your children you are loving you
are
a a a parent you're not just you know
this tough guy that walks in and
yells at everybody you know when you are
with your wife you are caring
when you are when you are uh outside you
are
a man you're not begging people you're
not losing that's
that that that honor that a man should
have right
you're not out there wearing pink
t-shirts and painting your nails and
thinking you're
you're a man because you're an mma you
can work out all you want bro i
scared no dude with a pink shirt and
painted males and plucked eyebrows and
all that right
that this is where allah will show you
the sharia
like this is where you're supposed to
how you're supposed to act
you know we have extremes in the ummah
today right
and alhamdulillah rasulullah showed us
that middle path
right that path where you no longer have
to flex something you just live by it
and then people know you're a man
inshaallah insha allah may allah make us
you know good man
i mean
all right bro with that being said i
think wonderful episode
if you made it this far hashtag bring
back
men and with that being said romney
handed off
allah
first and foremost the prophet
group of salallahu came to him and asked
you know we're dealing with these
horrible
doubts you know these doubts that if we
believe them they would lead to kufur
horrible doubts and the process he said
that this is good news
this is good news and obviously it's
very it sounds
upsy moronic how is you know big doubts
in faith
good news in the process he said it's a
sign of high iman and think about it
if you have catastrophic life-changing
doubts
about your religion it can't be anything
other than a sign that you have
high faith because you don't wake up in
the morning
and become worried that unicorns don't
exist
because you never believed in unicorns
in the first place so the fact that
these
doubts are worrying you is a sign that
you have high iman
that you actually believe in islam
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]